[Musique]
le géant du commerce en ligne Amazon va
installer une agence de livraison à La
Verrière le site est en travaux depuis
plusieurs mois et se situe à côté de
l'entreprise Valeo en bordure de la
nationale 10 selon nos confrères d'actu
78 l'activité devrait démarrer d'ici un
an et pour écrire plusieurs centaines
d'emplois deuxième site logistique dans
le département après celui de
Vélizy-Villacoublay il devrait permettre
de réduire les temps de livraison sur le
territoire les juniors de Trappes ont
remporté le championnat international
d'improvisation théâtrale le Mondial
d'impro avait commencé le jeudi 23 mars
dernier et c'est achevé par une finale à
la Meuse de Trappes ce dimanche 26 les 4
équipes françaises belges suisses et
québécois se sont affrontés autour de
matchs d'improvisation durant toute la
soirée se sont finalement les six
comédiens de la compagnie des clics
théâtre de Trappes qui ont soulevé la
coupe 6 ans après leur dernière victoire
c'est un yvelinois qui remporte le
concours des jeunes bouchées 2023 Thiago
Ferraz 19 ans s'est démarquée après
trois sessions d'épreuves ce dimanche 26
février au Salon international de
l'agriculture en compétition avec 17
autres candidats le jeune apprenti à la
boucherie lombaire de Versailles a été
évaluée par un jury de professionnels
notamment sur le travail de la côte de
bœuf le Salon international de
l'agriculture se déroule en ce moment au
Parc des Expositions de la Porte de
Versailles il se termine le 5 mars
prochain attention aux allergies les
Yvelines figurent déjà parmi les
départements placés en risque élevés de
circulation des pollens par le Réseau
National de Surveillance aérobiologie
beau temps oblige la floraison des
arbres précoces et leur pollen commence
déjà à irriter en particulier du côté
des aulnes et des noisetiers pour
prévenir les crises d'allergie 50 ans en
Yvelines a lancé un partenariat avec
l'IFI air life pollen une application
mobile gratuite qui permet de suivre la
météo des pollens sur le territoire avis
aux adeptes de jeux vidéo le prochain
tournoi eSport de Versailles aura lieu
le samedi 4 mars prochain de 11h à 18h à
l'Hôtel de Ville
tournoi pro FIFA 23 est super smash bros
ultimate seront organisés avec à la clé
400 euros de gain pour les trois
premiers gagnants de chaque tournoi des
animations Just Dance réalité virtuelle
ou encore Pokémon et Super Mario Kart
seront également au programme tout au
long de la journée vous pouvez danser
déjà vous inscrire pour les tournois sur
le site internet de la ville
[Musique]